We are going to see and are seeing a bunch of jobs get automated in a shock-like
way, because people need to find ways,
at least in the near future to do things with less human contact between human
beings. And we're seeing this moment,
that is a very deep reminder that people don't have
control over their economic fortunes, that all of a sudden,
a pandemic virus or something,
a technological dance could happen in your industry that, that lays you off,
or that destroys the economy in your town.
And so you really get into, I think your argument now for,
for UBI, um, which AI coronavirus,
like these things begin to almost operate as like metaphors for just a
shock and what happens to people during a shock.
And do you want to leave it up to Congress to argue about expanding UI benefits
during a shock?
So there's been a lot of movement actually in the Andrew Yang direction,
or as I often like to think about it,
the anti Lowery direction towards just giving people money, um, during this, uh,
during this pandemic,
and that's been a real policy shift that is not how we've done things during
past crises.
So I'd like to hear you talk a little bit about why you think that's happened
and what you think we can learn from its performance so far.
I'm very happy for it to be the anti Lowery direction.
And certainly, you know, I'm thrilled about anyone who gets on board,
doesn't matter why or what you call it. You know,
that there are now dozens of mayors around the country who are championing
guaranteed income, Michael Tubbs the original,
but there are now dozens of folks, Keisha Lance bottoms, uh,
Eric Arcedi and around the country who are committed to universal basic income
pilots.
And the reason as well is that now it's just common sense where you look around
and you see that there are tens of millions of Americans.
Who've gotten shoved out of the labor force because we don't need as many
bartenders, airline, attendants, security guards, ushers,
personal trainers,
you name it like there's so many jobs that required physical proximity that now
does don't make sense. And like you said, it's not no one's fault.
And so then you look around and say,
how are we going to get economic resources into the hands of these millions of
people?
And cash relief is the only sensible solution and $1,200 in
April. Uh,
going out had a really positive effect on many households and on
propping up our economy,
but we need to make that regular recurring predictable we've been
living off of the first cares act.
But then now that benefits have elapsed,
you're going to see distress and disintegration pick up in many,
many households and communities.
And there really is no feasible way to help so many households manage this
except for direct cash relief. And it's not just you,
me and Annie and mayor Tubbs at this point last I saw
76% of Americans are pro cash relief during the pandemic.
Uh, and 55% are now universal basic income.
So it's no longer the magical Asian man making this case.
It's the majority of Americans realize it's common sense and something we need
to do.
So there's a big jump between using cash transfer for
relief, which is what we've seen during the pandemic. And as you say,
it's already, uh,
as Mo Republican's already moved into a stance of opposition on it,
even though the pandemic is ongoing and moving to a basic income floor
and right in the middle of that jump is this argument that Republicans are
making on the UI on the unemployment insurance, why they won't extend the $600,
which is that if people can get paid and can
support themselves in their lives without working, they won't work.
And the point of American economic policy should be getting as many
people to work as we can, no matter what, no matter what job they have to take.
And so what is your argument to them?
What is your argument to Republicans who say, look, relief is fine,
but we do not want to be paying people not to work because we want people
working.
Agree and say,
the last thing you want to do is tie economic relief to job status or
employment status. So if you put cash into someone's hands and say,
you can have this cash, unless you start working. Um,
then it actually is a detriment to them going back out there as quickly as
possible. In some cases, I mean,
most people will still just be panicking until they find a job. And so to me,
this effect is overstated and overblown. Uh, but the extended exists.
You are right now tying a lot of this cash to employment status, I would say,
make the cash unconditional, and then you'll have a baseline.
And if you go out and get that part-time job,
because it's not ready to be a full-time job because the bowling alley or the
retail store is not at full reopening yet,
then you get to keep that money as opposed to right now saying, well,
wait a minute. If I take this job, then I stopped getting benefits.
So the problem right now is our existing legacy
infrastructure that ties the cash relief to not working.
I think the U S government has a spending constraint on it. Could,
could we do a UBI and a green, new deal and Medicare for all?
And just put it on the, put on the national credit card or do we have
limited resources? And we have to make choices between them.
The argument I made on the trail as are, um, which, uh,
I sent you to agree with is that we have a revenue problem in that the biggest
winners in the 21st century economy are paying zero or near zero in taxes very
often. And the most prominent example is Amazon,
the trillion dollar company that paid zero in federal taxes last year.
And so what I said to folks is like, look,
if you have Amazon paying zero in taxes,
you're going to have affordability problems for sure.
And that if you harness the gains from the Amazons and apples and
Netflix's of the world,
then you have a lot more revenue to work with very quickly.
And then if you put that money into people's hands,
that money does not disappear.
It ends up going right back into the local economy,
in the form of car repairs and daycare expenses and the
occasional meal out.
And those businesses all then create more opportunities and can create
virtuous cycles, uh,
that help end up creating jobs and human
wellbeing. But the,
the big thing as where I think is that we need to stop measuring our
economy in terms of these narrow economic outputs,
where if you try to figure out what's good for us by what's good
for the stock market, then you're lost. Uh, and so if we wait.
No, but I'm going to hold you on.
I'm going to hold you on this argument before you go into it,
because I want to stay on the,
I'm not measuring our economy by narrow economic outputs by GDP right here.
I'm the question I'm asking is, um, is can we afford it?
I know we need to pay for it. Yeah. Do we need to pay for things like this?
And what I would say is I know the, the, the corporate tax data on this stuff,
you know,
well enough to say that the list of things I just gave you Medicare for all UBI
and green new deal,
you could do everything that the folks I know who want to tax
corporations and rich people quite a bit more think we should do.
And in most cases, I want to do those things too,
and you wouldn't come near paying for the set of things. So,
so at some point you have to,
there is a question of whether or not these things are worth raising taxes,
for which I often think they are. Um, but taxes are our hard sell.
And then there's a question which you will sometimes hear people associate with
modern monetary theory and other things arguing,
which is that maybe we don't need to raise taxes for them. Now,
a lot of MMT years would say,
you can't do things this big without raising taxes cause you get inflation.
So that's a, that's an argument as well. Um, but,
but that's my question for you. Like,
do we need to figure out how to pay for it because we have to figure out how to
pay for it. Then it's going to be a, um,
it's going to force more choices and more sequencing.
I agree with everything you just said as well. And I also, I've seen the math.
I know the price tags on some of the things we're talking about,
but one of the things I said to folks on the trail was what is the
cost of not addressing climate change?
Or what would the costs of climate change be if we just let it wreak havoc and
ravage our country. And then people reflect on that for a second.
Most of them don't know the size of the economy pre pandemic was 22 trillion or
so. So if I throw that in there, then they say, well,
climate change is going to cost us trillions of dollars and thousands of human
lives if we were to do nothing. And so then you start thinking, okay,
the cost of inaction is in the trillions.
So then what is the benefit of our investing
in climate change mitigation,
particularly if you start measuring how we're doing based upon how we are
actually doing as human beings, like if you have a group of people drinking,
unclean water, or, uh, having their town submerged, uh, you know,
that that might not show up in certain economic indicators, uh, but it ought to.
So the way I'd answer your question is to say that, uh,
we should not be thinking we can just do everything under the sun, uh,
in terms of putting it on the government's bottom line,
but we can be much,
much more aggressive than we currently are about making large scale investments
in our own future, in our infrastructure,
addressing climate change and putting universal basic income into our hands.
Because in many cases,
a lot of these investments will end up paying us back in both human ways
and economic ways. Uh, and the,
the argument I make on the trail was that if you have universal basic income and
people's hands, does that improve our educational outcomes?
Does that improve our health outcomes?
Does that reduce the costs of incarceration?
Does that improve the ability of ex-convicts, uh,
their ability to reintegrate into society? Like there are many,
many things that we spend a ton of money on right now that we could
reallocate or alleviate if we invested directly in our people.
And that was what a lot of people were missing.
Oftentimes is that the investments you and I are describing actually pay off and
in many cases pay for themselves.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.